pis si on va faire la même chose dans sa
classe qui réunit des élèves de 4e 5e et
6e année isabelle nadau c'est qu'il y à
encore plus d'action ces jours ci la
gestion classique soucy c'est beaucoup
plus et les enfants sont énervés jamais
pas mal fatigué moi c'est un moment ci
de l'année c'est un des pires parce que
j'aime vraiment beaucoup
moi je fatiguais chien vous stressé
parce que celle ci à bas les prix en
période d'examens mais ce n'est pas
d'hier
il y à plus de 40 ans un directeur
d'école de québec avait étudié les taux
d'absentéisme des élèves et des
enseignants
j'ai découvert qu'elle pût y avait un
chômeur d'absence à la faveur d après un
séjour en france fernand paradis décide
d'importer l'idée du congé printanier
le conseil des commissaires a accepté
d'abord à québec c'est à 1977
trois ans après comme une traînée de
points d'où le 1-2 rachète a répandu à
toute la province pour ce pédiatre c'est
plus que jamais une bonne idée
les enfants ils sont de plus en plus
stressés tout le monde sait que là il
faut peut-être en profiter pour
s'éclater
vous avez vos écritures avec vous les
commissions scolaires ont le droit de
modifier le calendrier pourvu qu'il y
ait 180 jours d'école celle des
navigateurs au sud de québec avait songé
à ajouter une deuxième relâche à
l'automne mais après consultation a
finalement laissé tomber
est ce que les familles qui travaillent
qui sont séparés et tout pourrait
supporter 2 je sais pas mais c'est déjà
ça c'est déjà une c'est déjà un temps où
on peut en profiter pour faire quelque
chose je dirais comme bizarre je dois le
dire de délinquants en tous cas les
élèves d'isabelle nadeau semblent
satisfaits de la formule c'est pas ni de
deux petits jours de congés ni un mot de
congés c'est parfait une semaine pour
relaxer puis après quand tu reviens tu
es comme tu es tout rempli d ajuster
contente
tous n'en profiteront pas de la même
façon et à voir ce que lâche à volonté
moi je planifie pas c'est je me couche
peu je me couche je me réveille elle en
fait je veux aussi c'est une façon de
genre plus souvent de familles c'est ça
que je voyais des enfants avec les
particularités qui vont arriver qui dès
qu'il ya un un arrêt plus long qu'une
fin de semaine et comme un départ à
reprendre à chaque fois c'est comme un
début d'année tout le temps les
enseignants savent donc au retour ils
devront repérer ceux pour qui la relâche
aura été plus perturbante que bénéfique
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal